we'll talk about notation and
terminology
now don't forget i mean we've talked
about this for a long time now
in maths learning math is a bit like
actually learning most subjects is like
learning a new language there's all
these kinds of words
and ideas and terms and we introduce new
ones
so that we can describe things with
detail rather than say you know the
whole idea with degrees is rather than
say turn a little bit that way
you can say it turn 47 degrees in such
direction and so on okay
so this is just to help us be specific
so
first let's talk about three things
uh we'll go in this order lines
um raid and intervals
okay so what's a line this seems like a
simple question doesn't it
how would you define a line
it's a it's a thing like this it's a
yeah
how do i write that it's a thing like
this
i like that can we do anything better
verbally you know
oh
i like that because it draws on
some language we already know right
i want to go with a little more than
that right um a straight angle right
straight that particularly goes through
uh two points that we pick out
or you might say through two nominated
points
so if i'm writing it you should be right
again
that was about talking to your steps
for example okay
if i talked about a line a b
okay so a and b are sort of like two
points
right here we go a and b
okay now the line the straight angle
that goes through them
shouldn't close that okay it looks
something like this wow this is so dirty
seriously
but here's the important thing and this
is the distinction between these two
other things we're going to talk about
in a second
the line how far does it go
want well as far as you want i suppose
is how far you draw it but strictly
speaking if it's a line
it actually goes as far as a and b
yeah we're gonna get to that a second
this line that i want it actually goes
forever in both directions
okay ah that's actually important that's
what makes a line aligned
it goes forever
in both directions and that's what we
use
it goes forever in both directions and
that's what the arrows are about
okay now array or rays
exactly the same idea with one little
difference
okay it still still goes through you
know a couple of different points but
it doesn't go forever in both directions
it only goes forever in one direction
no mentions of boy bands please okay
so here's what it might look like
okay here's a point
okay and off it goes
there's an arrow okay so you can see it
starts
somewhere maybe i'll call that p okay
and it goes maybe goes to another point
q it keeps on going forever but
it stops it like if i were to go back
right i can't go on forever i actually
stopped there
that's a break so the line goes from
both directions the ray goes forever in
one direction
what do you think the interval might be
this also stops in one place
yes that's exactly right so here forever
both ways
here forever one way this one doesn't go
forever anyway
right it starts and stops
at specific points
so what did i have i had a b p q let's
make this x y
okay so an interval
is kind of like you know we use this
language right like an interval of time
means it's limited it's got a length
rays and lines they don't have like
because they go from you could never
measure it right
okay one more little word which is an
intersection
actually you're right it's a long word
intersection and then we can start
drawing
what is an intersection we actually have
intersections like
in roads and stuff right what's an
intersection jasmine
okay well what kind because not all
roads have intersections right
what kind of thing is it when roads
intersect
yeah okay it's when lines
or rays or intervals cross
okay so
for instance let's draw this
f okay so let's just describe this very
quickly
c d it starts and it stops so it's um
interval right e f
starts somewhere but then it goes
forever so it's uh rey
so i can say interval
cd and ray
ef intersect what should we call it
how about how about i heard t even
though it's not a t-junction but anyway
great okay
now just one last little word of caution
okay these definitions
are important um and they're correct
however
in normal language when we say oh draw
me a line
right usually we mean this
don't we usually lines refer to these
guys
usually okay um so i just want to
warn you that sometimes people will set
like in normal language
they'll speak like this but we're trying
to be more specific but these things we
actually distinguish between them okay
so if you say line what you really mean
is something